hello welcome to the session my name is
Jesse Walker I'm an editor at Reason
magazine I also wrote this book the
United States of paranoia I'm going to
talk a bit about the stuff that's in
that book and I'm going to start by
taking you back to january thirtieth
1835 a day when Andrew Jackson was
exiting a congressman's funeral and an
assassin drew a weapon and pointed it at
the president and pistol misfired the
gunman pulls a second weapon and it's
loaded but it to fails to fire Jackson
wields his cane and along with several
bystanders subdues two would-be killer
this was in the days of the
do-it-yourself Secret Service and the
guy turns out to be an unemployed house
painter by the name of Richard Lawrence
Lawrence later informed interrogator
that he was King Richard the third that
Jackson had killed his father and that
with Jackson dead money would be more
plenty he was judged insane they put him
in an asylum he died there three decades
later Lawrence was a lone nut or that
was the official story it wasn't long
before two witnesses filed affidavits
claiming to have seen Lawrence at the
home of the Mississippi senator George
Poindexter shortly before the attack
Poindexter was a noisy opponent of the
Jackson administration and various
projects and newspapers accused the
senator of plotting the president's
murder so did Jackson's allies in
Congress who quickly convened an
investigation Jackson himself told
biased Andrus after the assault that the
shooter had been quote hired by that
damned rascal Poindexter to assassinate
me some of Jackson's critics countered
with their own conspiracy theory
suggesting that the assault was a false
flag operation staged by the President
to gain public support and that this was
by why both of the guns failed to fire
and many jacksonian pointed their finger
at John Calhoun the former vice
president then the senator from South
Carolina arguing that it if he had been
not directly
involved in the assassination attempt he
had at the very least incited it with a
speech denouncing Jackson as an American
Caesar when the Republican writer John
Smith died described the crime 28 29
years later long after all those
investigations had dribbled out with
nothing to show for it he saw an even
more devilish plot at work Calhoun might
not have been directly involved in the
assault i conceded but then again maybe
he was and at any rate calhoun was part
of a larger force a southern cabal
called the slave power that would have
benefited if jackson had been put in the
ground and the slave power died was sure
was willing to more than willing to kill
a powerful man if he stood in their way
and if you're a fan of sort of 1970s
conspiracy movies like the parallax view
you're about to hear the antebellum
equivalent in 1841 president William
Henry Harrison told Calhoun that he
wasn't sure he was going to annex Texas
which the southerners wanted to add to
the Union as a slave state and harrison
promptly died now officially the cause
of death was pneumonia but died was sure
John Smith John Smith died was sure that
arsenic was to blame nine years later
died continued president Zachary Taylor
opposed to slave powers agenda in Cuba
in the southwest and so he was killed by
the same poison I also believed that
when president-elect James Buchanan
prepared to make some appointments that
the slavek rats disapproved of he
narrowly escaped death via one of the
most elaborate plots ever conceived on
februari 23rd 1857 according to die
southern agents poisoned all the bowls
containing lump sugar at the National
Hotel in Washington DC southerners died
explained drink coffee and coffee
drinkers use pulverized sugar so if you
poison the lump sugar the southern
diners aren't going to die but the tea
drinking northern diners including
Buchanan would be wiped out the future
president barely survived the illness
that followed intimidated by the
attempted assassination
I wrote Buchanan became more than ever
the tool of the slave power I won't keep
you in suspense there's not much
evidence for dies explosive charges you
can make a case that Harrison's doctors
did more to hurt and to help the ailing
president but no more than conjecture
supports the idea that anyone
deliberately killed him as opposed to
not being good doctors coroner's
debunked the Zachary Taylor theory when
his body was exhumed in 1991 and
Buchanan wasn't even present in
Washington on februari 23rd 1857 though
dysentery did break out at the hotel
when you can in-state there a month
earlier and again when he returned for
his inauguration and today those
outbreaks are usually attributed to a
sewage backup that contaminated the ins
food and water but at the time all sorts
of conspiracy stories were circulating
blaming everyone from a Chinese cabal to
a group of homicidal abolitionists
inconveniently for the whole sugar
theory tea and coffee the dead included
a southern Congressman John Quitman of
Mississippi but died was full of it but
when his book the adders then I was
published in 1864 the country was at war
with the south and when an expanded
edition appeared two years later under
the lengthy title history of the plots
and crimes of the great conspiracy to
overthrow Liberty in America the nation
was still reeling from the assassination
of Abraham Lincoln and in that
atmosphere dies book received a
respectful notice in The New York Times
it was excerpted in the Chicago Tribune
Republican papers praised it in
Philadelphia Harrisburg Trenton in New
York City and in Pennsylvania even the
Democratic East and Express proclaimed
it quote the most powerful book of the
century and I didn't invent his theories
from nothing he was drawing on rumors
that have been floating through wig and
Republican circles for years after
Lincoln was elected well before dies
book appeared several supporters of the
incoming president sent letters warning
him to watch out for the plotters who
had killed two of his predecessors one
citizen wrote a General Harrison lived
but a short time after he was installed
in office
and general Taylor lived but a short
time after he took his seat you sir be
careful at the Kings table what meet and
eat drink you take and another letter
informed Lincoln I have often heard it
stated by physicians that it was an
undoubted fact that our last two wig
presidents generals Harrison and Taylor
came to their sudden and lamentable ends
by subtle poisons that's underlined so
I'm trying to say poisons administered
in their food at the White House after
Lincoln died more than when minister
worked the supposed minister murders of
Harrison and Taylor into their sermons
reverend henry ward beecher not only
invoked their alleged assassinations in
an article for The New York ledger but
added the anti secessionist Democrat
Stephen Douglas to the list of alleged
victims during the effort to impeach
Andrew Johnson Lincoln's southern
successor congressman james mitchell
ashley brought up the same old
accusations he declared that harrison
taylor and Buchanan had been at a quote
poisoned for the expressed purpose of
putting the vice presidents in the
presidential office and in May 1868 an
extraordinary article appeared in the
New York Tribune that managed out dude I
accusing a democratic conspiracy of
engineering the city's malaria outbreaks
after commenting that Zachary Taylor
fell under the malarious vapors of
Washington and died because he was prone
to acting honestly and straightforward
The Tribune writer claimed that
Washington in subsequent years was free
of malaria that is for Democrats but
when the new Republican Party began to
gain strength and it was possible that
they might become the ruling power in
Congress the water of Washington
suddenly grew dangerous the hotels
particularly the national became Pest
houses and dozens of heretics from the
Democratic faith grew sick almost unto
death the contagions continued he
continued until Lincoln put the walls
and springs of the capital under the
care of loyal soldiers ending the
outbreaks but after Lincoln was deposed
a pattern returns and we had a return of
that bad water and two or three senators
Republicans mind
to our prostrated with southern illness
what does it mean why does it happen
that whenever the current sets against
the master demon of slavery and never at
any other time we find the air and the
water and the whiskey of Washington full
of poison and I really want to have like
a show on cable not for me someone to
call like the air the water in the
whiskey of Washington I think it would
be a great name so in the assassination
theorists were not the only Americans
worried about conspiracies of
slaveholders Lincoln himself believed
that he could clearly see a quote
powerful plot to make slavery universal
and perpetual and his famous house
divided speech if you read it is
actually filled with conspiratorial
speculations Senator Henry Wilson who
later served as vice president but the
idea pretty bluntly he said slavery
organized conspiracies in the cabinet
conspiracies in Congress conspiracies in
the states conspiracies in the army
conspiracies in the Navy conspiracies
everywhere for the overthrow of the
government in the disruption of Republic
of the Republic and meanwhile
southerners had elaborate conspiracy
theories of their own blaming blaming
slave revolts both real ones and
imagined ones on the machinations of
rebellion stoking abolitionists
treacherous land pirates and other
outside agitators so it was a paranoid
time but in America it is always a
paranoid time pundits tend to write off
political paranoia as a feature of the
fringe a disorder that occasionally
flares up until the sober Center can put
out the flames but they're wrong the
fear of conspiracies has been a potent
force across the political spectrum from
the colonial era to the present in the
establishment as well as the extremes
conspiracy theories played major roles
in conflicts from the Indian Wars of the
17th century to the war on terror today
they have been popular not just with
dissenters and nonconformists but with
individuals and institutions at the
center of power they are not simply a
colorful historical by way they are at
the country's core now unfortunately
much of the public perception
of political paranoia seems frozen in
1964 that's when the historian Richard
Hofstadter published the paranoid style
in American politics a very famous essay
which set out to the scribe what he
called a state of mind marked by heated
exaggeration suspiciousness and
conspiratorial frenzy and he detected it
in movements ranging from the
anti-masonic and anti-catholic crusades
of the 19th century to various left-wing
and right-wing folks at the time that he
was writing in the early 60s now there's
been half a century of scholarship since
then that is built on refuted and
otherwise amended various ideas and
Hofstadter's piece but that work doesn't
get nearly as much attention as the
paranoid style does and that's too bad
the essay does contain some real
insights but it also declared that
political paranoia is quote the
preferred style only of minority
movements and just to marginalize that
minority some more that it has quote a
greater affinity for bad causes than
good an earlier version of his article
hofstetter went further claiming that
the paranoid style usually affects only
quote a modest minority of the
population even if under certain
circumstances it can quote more readily
be built into mass movements or
political parties but educated elites
have conspiracy theories too I'm not
just talking about the times when
someone whose powerful signs on to sort
of a frenzied theory I they'd sort of
famous that Bill Clinton asked web
webster hubbell when he came into office
I want you to find two things out if you
go to justice who killed Kennedy and are
UFOs real you know and Richard Nixon was
a bit of a vince foster theorists so you
have things like that but I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
conspiracy theories that are embraced by
the center and the establishment mass
media and or government considered the
phenomenon of the moral panic it's a
time when fear and hysteria are
magnified distorted perhaps even created
by influential social institutions
Stanley Cohen didn't coin the phrase he
was a British sociologist but he was the
first to use it systematically and in
1972 he sketched sort of the standard
progression of a moral panic with
was that anything from you know the
rockers and the mods to LSD yeah let me
find the quote back a condition episode
person or a group of persons emerges to
become defined as a threat to societal
values and interests its nature is
presented in a stylized in stereotypical
fashion by mass media the moral
barricades are manned by editors bishops
politicians and other right-thinking
people socially accredited experts
pronounce their diagnosis and solutions
ways of coping are evolved or more often
resorted to the condition then
disappears submerges or deteriorates and
becomes more visible and an essential
feature of a moral panic is what calm
Cohen calls the folk devil and the folk
devil is an evil agents who serves as a
scapegoat for the threat and the folk
devil often takes the form of a
conspiracy it could be a satanic cult a
powerful gang of backwoods militia the
anti-prostitution panic of the early
20th century for example featured lurid
tales of a vast international white
slavery syndicate conscripted thousands
of innocent girls each year into sexual
service an influential book by a former
Chicago prosecutor at the time it was
called the girl who disappeared claimed
in the space of just three paragraphs
that the syndicate amounted to an
invisible government a hidden hand and a
secret power and he said in the same
time that behind our city and state
governments there is an unseen power
which controls them now coerced
prostitution did really exist it did
really exist but it was neither as
prevalent nor as organized as that kind
of wild rhetoric suggested but far from
being consigned to a marginal movement
as hofstetter would have suggested the
scare led to a major piece of national
legislation the Mann Act of nineteen ten
and it gave the first major boost in
power to the agency that would later be
known as the Federal Bureau of
Investigation within a decade the bureau
would be extending its purview from
alleged conspiracies of pimps to alleged
conspiracies of communists getting
another boost in power in the process
and after he took over Jagger Hoover was
very
good at playing that game you know now
he's going after the far right now is
going after the far left always finding
ways to turn whatever the paranoid
moment was into a way of expanding his
bureaucracies power but stories like
that are missing from Richard Hofstadter
famous essay the paranoid style drew
almost all of his examples all but one
and it's sort of a peculiar exception
for movements that were opposed to the
quote unquote right thinking people that
Stanley Cohen mentioned in his
definition of moral panic as Manning the
barricades against the folk Devils so
the result in hofstetter was a distorted
picture in which the country's outsiders
are possessed by fear and its
establishment usually is not there as
they had room for example for a what's
the quote greenback and populist writers
who constructed a great conspiracy of
international bankers but the essay said
nothing about the elites of the era who
perceived populism as a consumer product
of a conspiracy I'll give you a more
recent example of that kind of mirroring
this is this comes way after hofstetter
but involves people who quote hofstetter
a lot in June of 2009 you may remember
an 88 year old neo-nazi named James
winter curve on brun entered the
Holocaust Museum in Washington DC and he
opened fire and killed a security guard
that came 10 days after the murder of
the abortion doctor george tiller in
kansas and it to crimes wind up getting
linked in this kind of free associative
way into a pattern of rising right-wing
violence and some pundits tried to tie
the slayings to a smattering of other
crimes many dating back to the bush
administration which were linked only by
the fact that the criminals all hailed
from one corner or another of the
radical right the paranoid right as it's
often called but the critics of the
paranoid right turned out to be pretty
paranoid too having established this
crime wave to their satisfaction the
analysts quickly moved on to denouncing
the unindicted instigators they blamed
for it bonnie erbe of US News and World
Report pinned the museum's guard on
promoters of hate and said the shooting
was a clarion call for banning hate
speech in the New York Times Bob
herbert wrote that he can't help
thinking that the crimes were just the
beginning and that worst is to come and
if this was thanks in part to the
over-the-top rhetoric of the National
Rifle administration Association Paul
Krugman warned that right-wing extremism
is being systematically fed by the
conservative media and political
establishment the narrative was clear
the right-wing media was responsible for
right-wing violence and right-wing
violence was on the rise so with that
story in mind let me show you a chart
this is from a paper that was published
earlier this year by the combating
terrorism Center at West Point it counts
all the violent right-wing incidents
known to have happened in the u.s. each
year we're talking everything from
vandalism to the Oklahoma City bombing
the first thing you'll probably notice
is that this shaded park over on the
right hand side is a lot taller than the
shaded part on the left hand side and a
lot of the media reaction to the paper
focused on that though if they look
closer they would have seen that the
author of the paper actually mentioned
that that has a lot to do with the fact
that there's a lot better data now they
only started asking the police agencies
to start keeping track of hate crimes in
the like early on but if it's tricky for
I want what I want to actually focus on
here is 2009 when all those voices in
the media we're talking about rising
right-wing violence and we see it going
down and in 2010 remember there was too
few over a health care bill and the
warnings that tea partiers were going to
turn into storm troopers and it keeps
going actually down this is like the the
most interesting rise in violence I've
ever seen I'm finally in 2011 there's an
uptick just like you have upticks in
other years before national elections
the author of the paper thinks that
might be a pattern that happens around
election time maybe you'll notice 1996
it doesn't happen he says made us
because nobody really cared who won in
96 which might be true Bob Dole was
running I don't think he cared but at
any rate my point isn't to theorize
about what explains these zigs and zags
it's just to show you that this downward
slope happened in the exact two years
when everyone was telling us to expect
an upward slope it was
the story that we heard was a remarkable
reversal of the reality on the ground it
was paranoid and as anyone who's ever
read a comment thread about you know the
Koch brothers on a liberal blog can tell
you it's the kind of paranoia that can
frequently turn into conspiracy theories
I wrote this book it's got two big
themes first one I mentioned earlier
it's that conspiracy theories aren't
just a fringe thing the people in power
can be paranoid too and the others that
we can learn a lot from conspiracy
theories even when they are not accurate
some conspiracy theories are accurate of
course I got a chapter in here about the
revelations of the 1970s when all sorts
of ugly facts about the CIA and the FBI
and the IRS and the NSA came out a
couple of those initials may sound
familiar from recent stories so this is
not something it only happens in the
1970s but even when a conspiracy story
is not accurate at all it says something
true about the anxieties and the
experiences of the people who believe
and repeat it even if it says nothing
true about the objects of the theory
itself and when people try to talk about
political paranoia while ignoring those
facts I think you get really
one-dimensional discussions of the
subject and my book I set out to get
past that I hope I got at least a bit
pest it in my talk here today